on September the 13th the Federal
Reserve of the US central bank announced
a new program of quantitative easing the
creation of money to try and boost the
economy like Pavlov's dogs to stock
markets elevated as it has done on the
previous occasions the Fed announced
similar measures are these rounds of
monetary easing actually necessary and
will they succeed in boosting the global
economy quantitative easing involves the
creation of new money not the literal
printing of money as used to occur but
the creation of money with a click of a
computer mouse when an investor sells
government bonds or another asset to the
central bank the central bank credits
the bank account of that investor with
new money the aim is to encourage
investors to leave safe assets like
government bonds and invest in riskier
assets like shares and it's also to
stimulate lending in the economy by
keeping interest rates low does
quantitative easing work beyond lifting
the stock markets in the short term in a
kind of sugar high in the long run
critics fear that the effect of
expanding the money supply having more
money chasing fewer goods will be to
create inflation the positive case for
quantitative easing is that it has
prevented a very deep recession indeed
although central banks may be creating
money the biggest source of money
creation in the economy traditionally
has been the commercial banks and they
have been destroying money by shrinking
their balance sheets the best way of
thinking of it is as a bath as the
central banks are pouring in money
through the taps the banking system has
pulled out the plug at the other end and
the net effect if you look at the total
amount of money in the system
particularly in Europe is a balance in
money supply is barely growing at all so
without QE EB argument is the money
supply would be shrinking very rapidly
just what happened in the 1930s and what
led to the Great Depression
to sum up quantitative easing is a
controversial policy and an untested one
but the economists view is that it's
worth a try
the authorities have few other options
and
danger is that if they do not act the
world could fall into a very deep
recession